I was a child during the war and the
Germans came into took Slovakia I was
not yet six years old and at that time I
was living in Britain which was the
third largest city things were not
explained to me children at that time
were kept in ignorance of much of what
was going on politically or otherwise
and only when it impinge on actual
thommeri events were some explanations
given I have one recollection of the
German presence of that time which was
when Hitler supposed suddenly went
through the town and I do remember my
father saying that I was not to go in
the streets I first remember seeing the
German soldiers just walking on the
street
nothing happened much in the beginning
but slowly there was abuse and the abuse
came not so much from the Germans alone
as it came from the native population
the Slovaks themselves I remember coming
home one day and seeing my mother
serving on the star on my coat and I was
aware of the fact that this was a way of
singling us out and I remember saying
let's not do this because then we can't
hide and she said we have to that is the
decree and what happened in the town
itself was there closing in of the
neighbourhood the Jews we did not have a
ghetto and yet there was an ghetto
atmosphere there because what happened
is that certain neighborhoods where Jews
lived which were more elegant
neighborhoods they were told they had to
leave they could not stay so they had to
move into a smaller and smaller anklet
the main street of which was universal
and I had always been a child I used to
roam around to my parents despair but so
I got to know the city terribly well and
what I would do in order to be able to
continue that sense of freedom that I
had would be constantly to try to wear a
scarf to cover up the Jewish star and I
would pretend that if anybody addressed
me in some way I wouldn't understand
what they were saying but I did feel
that every exit into the town outside of
my immediate home was in to a very
hostile and dangerous environment that I
always could be found out and I would
have fantasies about what would happen
to me if they found me out and it was
always accompanied by my immediately
running back home to touch base I the
worst that I ever saw anybody was to get
a very thorough beating and curiously
enough I always expected the beating but
I never received it I never could
understand why and one day I do remember
asking a teacher whom I knew who lived
in the neighborhood as to why everybody
left me alone even though they saw me on
the street and she said to me that's
because you have blonde hair
somehow that seemed to me to make me a
little more acceptable but I was aware
of the fact that I didn't want to
identify with the slovaks
and yet I wanted the freedom of the town
which I had gotten so used to and I
wanted to know what was going on because
my parents weren't telling me much and I
wanted to explore and sense what really
was happening and I'm the better
worst part for me at that time was
watching the transports and the
transport would just suddenly appear and
I remember that we would hear certain
sounds of boots on the street and
usually whenever there was a transport
it was accompanied by 10 to 12 soldiers
coming marching together from house to
house and gathering all the people
knocking on the doors and saying you
have an hour people had only an hour in
which they could gather families
together often what would happen is if
the poor family was not together a child
would be sent out to bring in the rest
try to and that used to horrify me
because they would sometimes be a child
who would come running back crying I
don't know where pop is and so what
happened was that there was all these
transports would get together on the
street and the people would hit they're
hoping the family the rest of the family
would come and eventually what happened
is that which I did not know because no
one ever told me those things and it was
not possible to ask questions because
every time you ask the question they
just give you a slap and what I did find
out was that eventually families
reunited at a central post because when
the rest of the family came home and
asked whether they where they would rush
to the police station immediately give
themselves up to the Gestapo and in 1943
my family decided that they had to say
part of the family there so all these
transports coming and it was just a
monthly or currents and there would be
2,000 people sometimes in the transport
sometimes they'll be considerably less
we used to live in
of these foods and we lived on the
fourth floor in the apartment and my
parents were birth death and I had a
deaf sister so I became the yes I would
have to warn them that the transport was
coming and what I would do is we would
all rush in the back room and when they
knocked on the door we didn't answer we
were in the back room just trying to be
as quiet as possible and what happened
is that as a result of this the
responsibility was on me to always hear
what was going on because in any time I
heard 10 boots marching down around the
corner I'd run immediately home tell
everybody to go into the apartment and
sometimes we were together sometimes we
were not and though we used to pray that
nobody would be coming up the stairs
just at the same time and he got so that
we all got to be very very good in
spotting what happened is we developed
eyes that looked for everything and I
was the ears and so in the middle of the
night sometimes people would come up the
stairs but there were no transport
collections at night but they would be
what they called neighborhood spies
people who tried to find out whether the
family was still there and so on and we
had to watch out for that too and I
ended up so that I was constantly
listening and what I was able to
identify sounds and but in by 1943 my
parents realized it was just hopeless
that there was no point in trying to
live in this fearful way and so they
decided to send my sister and me to a
farm family out in the country for which
they paid great sums and I had to hide
the fact that I was Jewish and I
remember my mother taking over the store
of my clothes again and sending me off
and this was English I would say around
the spring or the summer of 1943 I would
I was taken by a person who was also
deaf to his mother's home in the
countryside somewhere in there near the
Tatra mountains at the foothills and I
was introduced as a very distant
relationship was parents were in the
hospital and second I had to be taken
care of for a certain amount of time
until I got the message to come back I
was told never to tell anyone I was
Jewish I was told that even though I
didn't have to go to church that I had
to pretend that I everything question
was very familiar to me and very desired
by me so that for example if their
priest went by I had to cross myself
it used to be terrible to do that for me
because I thought that I was going to in
some way have to pay for this but I
nevertheless II knew that I had my
sister as well to take care of who was a
year and a half younger than myself and
I never saw my parents again afterwards
in the spring of 1944 the Sun came back
to the farm and announced to me that my
parents had failed to pay for the last
five months my stay there and
consequently somebody else was going to
take care of us in Bratislava itself so
when we went back to Bratislava there
were various people we knew who had
papers forged papers and they told us
that it would be impossible for us to
they had to forge papers when he said oh
where are our patterns they said they
didn't know but they were still in
hiding
they deliver they never told us that
they had already been taken by the last
transport out of gratis lemma and
finally I remember one evening hiding on
the third floor of the building which
was really the place where a tailor kept
his workshop and we had to stay out of
the place all day long because he had
work him in there and as he explained to
us that those many of those workmen were
very anti-semitic and if they knew that
we were there spending the night in the
dark they would betray us without a
doubt and so I remember spending the
days for three weeks on the streets
going into shops when I had to go in
going into the church going all over the
place
I remember one episode which was very
harrowing was when somebody who knew my
parents recognized me and it was very
easy to recognize me at that time
because I am very blonde very tightly
curled hair sort of like an afro in
blond and he immediately says come here
I'm going to take care of you and I knew
immediately that I just could not trust
him in fact my I had lost trust in
everybody I was very suspicious and very
careful to watch and listen for any
force or difficult nerve ins and I said
no I wasn't going to come and I started
to run and he chased me and it was a
very good thing that my knowledge of
Bratislava came to my aid because I was
able to weave my way around streets and
corners and little openings in buildings
and finally I managed to lose him I
noticed one thing when I came back to
Bratislava that there were no more
transports there were no more gatherings
and the transports used to terrify me
because the speed of them was so
horrendous where they were trying to
force they would yell at the people and
say get out get out quickly get out
gather together you can't take this
suitcase you can take this suitcase only
a little bit with you no you mustn't
take this blanket and they would just
force the blanket away in the process
also there would be a lot of base
hitting of especially of old people and
of sick people and children and shoving
and pushing and there's gatherings of
people just terrified me I've nearly it
was a way of behaving which I could
never experience except in not even in
nightmares I even remember my nightmares
as being mild compared to this but what
was terrible is that it was the behavior
- it's the very people of that day
Jewish religion says you must have a
great deal of kindness which are the
sick they're old and the children and I
saw everything being done which was
opposed to what I believed in and what I
had grown up in and I remember when I
came back to Bratislava one of the
things I noticed that those transports
had seized so it was really in one sense
of relief but in another sense a
terribly scary thing because I suddenly
realized that I might be the last one of
the few last years left in the town that
they all had been taken except for the
three or four people I knew who were on
forged papers and the thought of being
one of the last Jews was terrible I
couldn't bear it
I kept thinking no I don't want to be
the last one in life and I must have
realized that many of them went to death
because
so otherwise I wouldn't have said that I
don't want to be the last one alive and
finally after three weeks of living on
the streets being terrified of the
thought of meeting the man who had
chased me again being tired part of
meeting anyone who knew me as a jewel I
had been away from the town for about
nine months so I had hoped that somehow
I in growling I had somehow become less
noticeable but after three weeks of
living like that the man said the people
had gotten suspicious because they found
bread crumbs and they were complaining
and they thought that the owner of this
workshop had harbored some fugitives and
so he finally told me he couldn't keep
me I had to find some other
accommodation and I took my suitcase and
my sister looking for a place to stay
and I would go to places where I knew
people who were Christians I knocked on
the door and they slammed the door right
in my face and not saying you were not
explaining just as if I were just a
beggar at the door and they just closed
the door in my face and finally I went
to their home these friends of my
parents were living on the forged
Passport and they did the same thing and
then I knew I think that was the last -
after there was nothing for me to do for
two days we were scrounging we had no
money we were scrounging around trying
to find food and finally I said to my
sister and we can't live that way but I
died on the street so we might as well
just go to the police
and I went to the police and I said my
name and I said my
name and I said I'd like to join them
and the police were used the first
laughed and then they realized that I
was perfectly serious
and they suddenly I realized that I had
presented them with a problem they
didn't know what to do with me they
didn't know what to do so they told me
that I could sit on the bench and I
spent the night in the police station on
the bench while they were trying to find
out what to do with me
that didn't explain anything to me one
of the policemen
I remember said well they are trying to
find where your parents are and they
finally must have found out somehow
because it's immediately put on a clock
and driven into Hungary and that was in
Sarab which was a gathering point for
the last remaining transports coming out
of practice number because nothing was
going directly from Bratislava I arrived
there to discover that the play two
weeks before my parents had been put on
the train to Auschwitz this was the
first time I heard about Auschwitz I
didn't know anything about it and I was
finally put on one train and it was a
cattle car and I in some ways was
terribly relieved to be there because
here I was among Jews again they were
all strangers but still the fact that
they were Jews was very important to me
I was at that time I was nine years old
and I had my sister who was suddenly a
half and to whom I had to explain
everything who had to be basically taken
care of because she only knew the sign
language and I could sign with her but
she didn't know how to communicate
with their hearing people and so I was
really constantly having to hold her by
her hand so that because I couldn't call
her I couldn't do anything I couldn't
ever lose sight of her because the in
the milling of the people who could have
been separated and we finally were put
on the train and I was told that I would
be going to Auschwitz and to me of
course it was just an image of my
rejoining my parents being on the train
for five days and doing the whole
process of our trip we wouldn't have to
stop because there was bombing going on
sometimes the bomb sounded as if they
were very close and we thought that they
would get the plane and we were I would
say maybe 300 people in each car and my
sister and I sat on the suitcase the
whole five days we were in the Train
and at one point the bombing at one
point sounded as if it were the front of
the car had been hit it was so loud and
their car itself jumped tracks and we
were stuck there for what seemed to me
forever and one day as we were sort of
sitting in the car we were told that we
would not be going to Auschwitz that we
will be rerouted and I remember having
to get out of the car because it had
jumped the tracks and there was no way
for it to move and crossing the tracks
going into another car then spending
another three days in the tracks they
did the Germans that provide food for us
but it was so many more it was just a
slice two or three slices of bread and
water in that was or and summer
was so weak we could barely make it
across the tracks to the other so we had
to help each other and for some strange
reason my sister and I maybe because we
were so young we were somehow had
managed to get through the ordeal of
being a two days cooped up in a very
tight space and after about three days
we had I think bergen-belsen and then
there was a long march and the March was
the most horrendous thing I've ever
experienced because after eight days the
people just were in no shape to walk
from the station to the reception house
at the camp and there it that March
which was seemed endless it was looked
enormous ly long maybe in my mind now it
seems almost three hours but it couldn't
have been but there we would slowly walk
and the Germans kept shouting and
yelling no retractions and dogs and they
would fall on the people and asking them
to hurry and hurry and I remember the
first night falling asleep I had nothing
to eat for a long long time nothing to
drink but I fell asleep and I remember
thinking like had played a terrible
trick on me because I was in an
Auschwitz with my parents and I remember
saying to myself as I fell asleep I will
never stop looking for them when we came
in with the transport to bergen-belsen
the separation occurred in the train
station already so that when we started
our march i already noticed that there
were no men around and no boys and when
i came to look at those
transports I noticed that one of the
soldiers we used to be very irritated
with me all the time especially when I
started to ask in perfect German could I
please call out my mother's name I knew
my mother couldn't hear me but I thought
maybe somebody would who knew that she
was deaf would tell her that I had been
calling out her name and I would call
out her name over and over again about
doing that one day for about the fifth
or sixth time the soldiered so lost his
temper he just picked me up and flung me
against a stone and I lost consciousness
at that time and the immediate result
was that I lost for temporarily my
hearing which was in some way to me a
sense of tremendous worry because I had
to be my sister's yes I had to hear from
her and I was afraid that I had really
had my hearing permanently damaged but
after about five or six days my hearing
came back later on
in bergen-belsen I realized that my
sister was being watched by the camp
doctor they I do not know who it was he
was a german doctor but he would come by
the children's barracks all the time
come to my sister pinch her cheeks for
her years and try to be very friendly
with her and then one day he said to me
that he would be able to give us all
interesting chocolates if I allowed my
sister to go into the hospital for a few
days and my sister was perfectly well so
I couldn't understand why you wanted in
the hospital or and I just was very
sassy and I said no you are not because
if you are I'm going to pick
you and I went up and sort of said I I'm
really going to I'm serious
I mean it and so he laughed and then
forgot about it later on the black
artists have told me that he had hoped
to be able to use my sister for
scientific research right across from us
with a channel house filled with corpses
not just the inside but overflowing all
over there were corpses all over I lived
walked beside that people and after a
while it just got to be so that one
noticed and one had to say to oneself
I'm not going to see with this
I'm not going to recognize anyone in
this person who is lying there and it
got to the point where I realized that I
had to close my eyes to a number of
things and otherwise I would not have
survived even at that time because I saw
people around me going mad
I was not only having to live with all
these things but with madness one thing
I did receive from the woman in said it
was a small bag of tea which I was able
during the time of the typhus epidemic
to exchange for a vaccine for my sister
and I was told it was a typhus vaccine
whether it was won or not I'm not sure
but the fact is my sister never did get
the typist I did and so one of the
saddest thing in my life has been that I
have known a collection of the
liberation because I was totally error
with the tigris I have no recollection
of what happened when the English came
to bergen-belsen
I was very near deaths head I had to
wait another two days for the English I
would not have survived
and the it's I have proved it on that
that I have not been conscious at what I
consider to be the most important
experience I came to Sweden I was given
over to a doctor in Sweden who
immediately decided to fatten me up
because I weighed at the age of 11 I
weighed as much as a three-year-old
child and had a big fat belly
my sister is alive she is came to New
York with me she went to a school she
went to the Lexington School for the
Deaf she married she has three children
coming to the United States was a great
shock I happen to come on in August of
1948
is the hottest day in the history of the
United States I had come from Sweden and
walked out of the plane and I remember
turning around and saying I'm going back
because not only was it very very hot
but at the airport greeting this plane
which had taken us 24 hours to fly from
Stockholm to New York I was suddenly
faced by the whole panoply of black
faces nobody in Sweden had told me that
there were weakness in the United States
I knew that they were in Africa but to
suddenly come into New York and see all
those black faces I was sure I had come
into the wrong country I was supposed to
come to the United States here was this
hot place with all the black people I
thought it was some way in Africa I had
landed somewhere in Africa it was so
but the train went to another place
that's right it was exactly it was it
was my having in some way sense that
life is playing tricks on me all the
time that I wasn't going to the places I
thought I was going to and then at a
time when my relatives waiting for me
none of whom I knew I had never met them
they had all left long before I was born
they were yelling and screaming grenade
and Arna so I knew that I was where I
was supposed to be but what was strange
was having to get adjusted not only to a
totally different millio but to
relatives I had absolutely no inkling of
you
you